schönen guten tag alle miteinander an
diesem sonnigen tag
diese wahl hat uns allen einen auftrag
gegeben in unserem land und vor allen
dingen uns als demokratischen parteien
die in den bundestag wieder einbezogen
sind ein neues bündnis zu schaffen dass
es auch ein historischer moment in
unserer gesellschaft in unserem land
weil es eine politik voraussetzt die
sich nicht auf den kleinsten gemeinsamen
nenner ausrichtet sondern für einen
wirklichen aufbruch vor eine wirkliche
erneuerung in dieser gesellschaft sorgt
gerade bei den großen zukunftsaufgaben
in diesem land wo es über jahre
stillstand gegeben hat jetzt ein
aufbruch gemeinsam zu schaffen und das
auch in einem bündnis was es in einer
dreier konstellation in deutschland so
noch nie gegeben hat dafür sind
vertrauensvolle gespräche notwendig die
haben wir in den letzten tagen im
kleineren kreis getan dafür haben wir
uns heute zwischen bündnis 90/die grünen
und fdp in großer runde getroffen um den
auftrag den uns die wählerinnen und
wähler gegeben haben für eine wirkliche
erneuerung in diesem land zu sorgen
schon einen ersten kleinen schritt zu
gehen
guten tag meine damen und herren die
bundestagswahl war eine zäsur die
menschen haben sich gegen den status quo
entschieden es soll etwas neues in
deutschland entstehen wir treten jetzt
gemeinsam in eine offene situation in
der vieles in unserem land neu
begründet und neu gegründet werden kamen
die quellen unseres wohlstands
die technologischen grundlagen unseres
zusammenlebens die möglichkeiten
sozialer sensibilität sicherung und
aufstiegs bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
sind die politischen kräfte die sich am
stärksten gegen den status quo gewarnt
haben wir fühlen uns gemeinsam
beauftragt in deutschland einen neuen
aufbruch zu organisieren fraglos wir
haben den status quo der vergangenen
jahre aus unterschiedlichen perspektiven
bewertet und kritisiert deshalb führen
wir jetzt gespräche darüber wie das
gemeinsam trennende überwunden werden
kann welche brücken gebaut werden können
etwa im bereich des klimaschutzes und
dem bereich der finanzen gibt es
zweifelsohne unterschiede und jetzt geht
es darum diese brücken zu suchen der
prozess hat heute in einer guten
atmosphäre begonnen er ist allerdings
nicht abgeschlossen wir spüren dass
alleine die art und weise dass und wie
wir miteinander sprechen und wie wir um
lösungen uns in einer sehr
vertrauensvollen atmosphäre bemühen für
viele menschen anlass zu hoffnung und
motivation ist dh die art und weise dass
uns die wir sprechen könnte auch schon
eine botschaft einen erneuerungs
versprechen für das land insgesamt seien
dafür wir uns in einer großen
gemeinsamen verantwortung
der guten tag auch in meiner seite
anknüpfend an das was christian lindner
gerade gesagt hat muss man ja
feststellen dass wir beiden parteien für
veränderung stehen aber nicht
notwendigerweise für die gleiche form
von veränderung insofern ist schon enorm
was in den letzten tagen passiert ist
dass wir miteinander eine
gesprächskultur aufgebaut haben die eine
sachorientierte diskussion möglich macht
denn dies ja nun auch notwendig und so
war es heute auch es für eine sache
orientiert die diskussion und auch
unsere wahrnehmung ist dass das was nach
dem wahlkampf eben auch drohte großes
kuddelmuddel orientierungslosigkeit
irgendwo gott was haben wir denn da
gewählt wir sollten daraus werden reiner
neugier vielleicht auch einer suche nach
orientierung gewichen ist und dass die
grünen und die fdp zusammen einen großen
teil dieser orientierungs gebenden kraft
stellen können das merken wir in diesen
gesprächen
es geht jetzt so weit dass wir auch
unsere bilateralen gespräche fortsetzen
werden aber das kennen sie den zeitplan
die parteien jetzt auch mit den anderen
möglichen
koalitionspartnern in die sondierungen
eintreten werden wir also mit der spd
und danach mit der cdu die fdp mit der
spd und danach ebenfalls mit der cdu und
dann wird man sehen welche dynamik die
nächsten tage vielleicht wochen
entfalten wichtig ist es ja richtig in
einem prozess reinzukommen als wir
wollen die schraube schräg einsetzen
wird sie nie wieder gerade diese frau
bestenfalls in den ersten tagen sehr
gerade eingesetzt worden insofern war
das glaube ich ein ganz guter start auf
dem weg zur bildung einer neuen
regierung
beim 1
also wir haben ja gerade deutlich
gemacht dass sich 2017 nicht wiederholen
soll das heißt dass per live ticker aus
vertraulichen gesprächen berichtet wird
und da das vorgespräche sind werden wir
auch alle weiteren fragen was es auf dem
brötchen käse oder wurst gab oder wie
wir strategisch weiter vorgehen dazu
jetzt weiter nichts sagen sondern so wie
robert habe gerade gesagt hat es gibt
jetzt weitere bilaterale gespräche auch
in vertraulichkeit
dazu möchten wir nicht sagen wir haben
sehr vertrauensvolle gespräche und zum
gemeinsamen
prozess gehört eben auch dass wir nicht
fortwährend zwischenergebnisse und
wasserstandsmeldungen nach draußen geben
wie anna lena dörr wochen christa nimmt
man ja gerade gesagt haben zeigt ein
system geist der gespräche und ich würde
sagen der letzten tage aus wenn nicht
alles was man weiß immer zum markte zu
tragen und so haben wir uns auch
vereinbart und daran werden wir drei uns
vor allem halten wie sollen wir sonst
von den kolleginnen und kollegen
erwarten dass sie sich daran halten die
gespräche werden sache orientiert und
konzentriert geführt in einem guten und
einem würde ich sagen fast
geschichtliche bewusstsein dass man
jetzt was gutes hinkriegen muss und wir
werden dann uns an die öffentlichkeit
wenden wenn wir der meinung sind es gibt
es was zu erzählen
darauf verständigen mit wie man dann in
trilateralen echten versicherungs
gespräche gibt als bislang
gemeinsames vorgehen von grünen
wir sind heute schmallippig auch dazu
kommen wir heute nichts weiteres sagen
weil die bilateralen gespräche das
wissen sie auch vom zeitplan ziehen sich
dann auch erstmal die nächste woche
robert habeck anna lena berger christian
lindner dort zusammen betonen immer
wieder dass die gespräche vertrauensvoll
und vertraulich geführt werden sollen
ich fast noch mal ganz kurz für uns drei
im studio zusammen also annalena
baerbock durfte als erstes nach vorne
gehen da würde ich einfach mal in der
interpretation sagen das ist einfach
ladies first und hat nichts mit dem
spiel zwischen bernburg und harbeck zu
tun sie haben betont der aufbruch muss
gemeinsam geschafft werden christian
lindner sprach von einer zensur gegen
den status quo und man fühle sich
gemeinsam beauftragt einen neuanfang für
deutschland zu organisieren es müssten
brücken gesucht werden der prozess sei
in einer guten atmosphäre begonnen
wurden aber noch nicht abgeschlossen
christian lindner betonte dass die art
und weise wie man miteinander gesprochen
hat für ihn sehr große zuversicht aus
ist auch robert habeck unterstützte das
indem er sagte sei enorm was wir in
wenigen tagen an vertrauen aufgebaut
haben grüne und fdp könnten gemeinsam
orientierung geben das würde man in den
gesprächen sehen und das sei vielleicht
auch in deutschland so etwas wie eine
neugier entstanden und diese beiden
parteien könnten diese orientierung
geben hat er noch das schöne bild davon
benutzt wenn die schraube gleich erst
mal schief eingedreht ist dann wird das
nichts mehr und er habe das gefühl dass
diese schraube gerade herein gedreht
würde und dass es gespräche in einem und
da wurde es dann richtig feierlich sogar
in einem geschichtlichen bewusstsein
gegeben habe klingt alles ziemlich gut
oder ja wobei man da auch wieder auf die
bremse drücken muss denn sowohl
christian linder also robert habeck
haben nach ihren statements zu der guten
atmosphäre und dem guten auftakt der
gespräche doch auch deutlich gemacht
dass werden jetzt noch durchaus
anstrengende tage und wochen und es gibt
natürlich auch noch trennen ist das muss
man ganz klar sagen das haben auch alle
drei betont sowohl annalena baerbock und
robert habeck als auch christian lindner
das war von unterschiedlichen richtungen
kommt um probleme zu lösen und
entscheiden wird jetzt sein diese
unterschiedlichen richtungen irgendwie
zusammen zu binden wenn man gemeinsam
regieren möchte und dann haben sie noch
mal betont robert habeck betonte dass
vor allem jetzt muss man sehen wie weit
trägt das denn jetzt geht es in die
gespräche mit den anderen beiden
parteien und da muss man halt sehen was
da wirklich an gemeinsamer linie
verkauft wird sozusagen oder was da an
neuen impulsen ja auch hereinkommt in
den einzelnen gesprächen der spd mit der
fdp und der spd mit den grünen danach
kann die situation schon wieder anders
aussehen klar ist dass sich beide als
reform parteien sehen die etwas am
status quo ändern wollen also groko das
haben beide deutlich gemacht wollen sie
auf keinen fall mehr das wird ihnen
nicht verhandlungen auch natürlich eine
rolle spielen tendenziell könnten
natürlich spd und union immer noch eine
gemeinsame regierung geht und hätten
auch eine mehreren deutschen bundestag
also da haben beide gesagt nein das
wollen wir auf keinen fall wir wollen
auf jeden fall mitregieren und ich
bleibe dabei es sieht ein bisschen
stärker nach einer ampel aus denn einer
koalition mit der union aber wir werden
sehen wie die gespräche am sonntag
verlaufen
[Musik]